so those of you guys who are coming in
this is the github repository for
everything that we'll be working on so
even after the tutorial the notebooks
I'll publish them all here what I do
want you guys to do is if you can go to
that link that's highlighted up here and
if you don't know your way around github
you can click this green button here and
click download zip and that will at
least download everything in the most
important part about that is because the
datasets that we'll be working with are
all stored in this repository so if you
want to follow along at least you can
follow along that way so I'll just keep
talking a little bit about setting up so
when you download this if you download
the I'll assume that you downloaded the
zip version of it and I'm not going to
assume that everyone in the room knows
get unzip it somewhere that's convenient
so the desktop is probably a useful
place at least for the tutorial for
those of you on Windows and Macs
I sort of assumed that you're running
the anaconda distribution of Python and
so if you open up the anaconda navigator
if this is the first time you're opening
it and might take a while take a little
bit of time but there is a button in
there that says Jupiter notebook or
Jupiter lab and once you click that a
browser should open up what I am going
to show is a little bit different
because this is a Linux machine but I'm
just hide all this random other stuff
before something I regret shows up on
the screen
[Music]
all right so if you use the Anaconda the
Navigator and you click on Jupiter lab
or Jupiter hub eventually you might get
a screen like this if you're if you
click Jupiter lab I mean Jupiter hub
sorry
Jupiter notebook if you want there is a
new ish foreign that you can play with
called Jupiter lab I'll probably end up
using Jupiter lab for the for this
tutorial and Jupiter lab is you know you
can think of it as like the next
iteration of the notebook system it's
pretty handy because you'll have a lot
more convenient access to everything so
you can browse your files right away
what's also really cool is CSV files can
also be rendered as spreadsheets in
Jupiter lab which is really useful if
you're just playing around with data
what's also really useful is you can
have multiple notebooks open at the same
time and you can have like two views of
the same thing which is like really
useful that was like one of the things
people were complaining about all the
time and so SuperLab if you haven't
played with that yet I would highly
suggest looking into it so hopefully
everyone has that up and running and
totally just realized and this whole
chaos I forgot to pull up my notes for
the whole course
for those of you guys who have questions
feel free to raise your hand someone
will run to you with the microphone you
can totally interrupt in the middle I
don't really matter too much about that
and sorry give me one second I am
pulling out my notes all right oh that's
not helpful render works alright so this
is a very introductory tutorial so if
you've never worked through pandas
before or worked with tabular data in
Python this is generally the target
audience that I'm aiming for the main
difference about this one is I'll skip
over a lot of stuff and get right to the
actual Tidy data tidying data portion of
it which I found to be the most liked
that was the reason why like I switched
over to using like Python or R to do
analysis just because doing these data
manipulations was just sort of magical
for me so that's sort of the general
pace that will go in if you've seen
other tutorials that I've given you'll
notice that like I pretty much jump from
like chapter one - like chapter six but
we'll cover holes along the way so don't
worry too much about it so hopefully you
guys have the data sets downloaded and
you have this notebook system open and
we'll sort of just live code along and
just talk through the commands as I go
through them so python comes with a
bunch of libraries and by default just
to make things faster to load you know
they don't load up everything at one go
so we have to import our oops let me
make this bigger so we have to import
libraries so the library we're going to
lose it use is called pandas and this is
our library for reading in tabular data
and so if we want we can now use pandas
they have a special function in there
called read CSV to read in CSV files so
we can assign what we load in to a
variable so we'll call it DF or data
frame
and in Python when you load in a
librarian you want to call a function
within a library you use this dot
notation so we were saying in this
pandas library we want to use a really
specific function out of it and the
function we want to use is called read
CSV and if you're wondering how I got
that thing to pop up you hit the tab key
and it will do that auto-complete for
you so in read CSV if you hit shift tab
in the notebook it would pull up the
function signature for you and the first
thing that it will take is the file path
or buffer so this is pointing to the
file path or file that we want to use
the ooh I forgot I need to do one more
important thing when you're if you're in
the Jupiter notebook system the right
now I am in the data folder so you saw
before that we were originally here I
click data and then I created a new
notebook in here right so that's what I
ended up doing so when I hit like dot
slash meaning like looking my current
directory in hit tab all the data sets
that I have are in there and in the next
notebook I'll show you what happens when
you move your notebook into another
folder so the first data set we're going
to look at is called Gapminder TSV and
you can look by the extension that this
is a tab separated value file not comma
separated so we actually need to give
read CSV a different parameter called
sepals slash key so backslash key and
this is how we tell pandas hey like by
default you read CSV files or comment
delineate files but in this example we
actually have a tab delimited file so
this data frame thing in Python is an
object so DF and if we want we can print
out all of DF and we'll just give us the
entire data set dumped out to the screen
but one really convenient way is this
method called head so we say DF head
with round brackets it'll just give us
the first five rows and when you're
reloading in datasets for the first time
this is really useful because you just
really want to make sure that like your
column really like your colony
got loaded properly sometimes datasets
like the first row is like an empty
column in which case like and what might
not load properly or maybe you don't
have columns in your dataset at all you
know and pandas will by default treat
the first row as like column name so you
might end up with something wonky so you
always want to look at like head just to
make sure that everything is loaded
properly so if we look at our data set a
data frame in pandas really has three
different components
there's the column names on the top
there is this index on the left so in
this case the index is really the road
name the row number and then there's
like the body of the data frame and if
you ever kick so you can access those
three components however you want
so we could say DF columns and that will
give us just the columns of our data set
you'll notice that columns does not have
round brackets it's just an attribute of
the data frame it's not really like a
function that's being called if we want
to access the quote-unquote row names
its DF dot index and that's how you get
the index portion so if you if you end
up going down pandas and you work with a
lot of time series data you'll end up
setting like the day time as the index
so you can access your data set access
different rows by the time of day that
way and then in the middle right here
like the actual body of our data frame
that's called the values and so this
this is one way if you need like hey I'm
trying to take this data frame object
and pump it into this other library and
this other library like does it
understand what a data frame is and in
and it works with like the numpy arrays
this is how you essentially get like the
numpy array version of your data set
alright so it used to be you have to do
this when you were working with
scikit-learn all the time but they sort
of handled the ability to work with
pandas dataframe objects but
occasionally especially if you work with
number that assumes that everything is a
numpy array and so sometimes you will
end up having to use dot values just to
get the the numpy representation of your
data set one other thing when you're
working with python very often is this
type function this is really useful when
you're working in python
you get some weird error and you just
want to know why and what the type of
your objects are so you can see here
this is a panda's data frame object you
see panda's data frame right here all
right so what else do you do when you
like first load up your data set for a
first time well there's this attribute
called shape and it gives you the number
of rows and columns in your data set so
this data set this Gapminder data set
has 1704 rows and six columns all right
and so like if you can imagine you have
like million rows or hundreds of columns
instead of inspecting each and one of
them you know this is a quick way to
make sure like did I get my data
properly if we're reading in data from
like instruments this stuff usually ends
up being really specific like every time
this instrument spits out a data set is
300 rows and five columns and this is
one way you can check that light the
instrument didn't like dump out a bad
data set for you what ends up happening
sometimes you forget I forget as well
these attributes like columns sometimes
I'll put columns with round brackets and
you just might forget and so if you end
up doing something like DF dot shape
with round brackets meaning like hey I'm
calling the shape function on the data
frame and not just the shape attribute
you'll get an error message something
like this in this case it says it's a
tuple object it's not callable because
what got reasons we turn back is that
tuple so think of that as like python
list that you can't change and so it
doesn't know what that this as a
function is mean does that's why you get
an error like that
so other stuff that you do if you don't
really have too many columns one really
useful thing is just say like hey give
me the info of this data frame and this
gives you the type on the first row so
this tells us it's the data frame we
have 1704 rows and they're labeled zero
to 1703 so this label is that index that
we saw earlier and then down here in the
middle it gives us all of the columns so
on the left-hand side it gives us the
tells us there's six columns here on the
left-hand side the column name in the
center it gives us the number of non
null objects so in this case you can see
that like hey we don't have any missing
data in our data set
and on the right hand side it tells us
the type of information stored in that
column so if you see object in pandas
that means it's a regular string object
but you can see in this data set we have
integers we have floating-point numbers
as well and there's other types in
pandas as well so if you work with like
other statistical languages like are
like a factor you'll see that encoded as
a category in Python or in pandas all
right so let's actually do something
with our data set let's start filtering
and slicing out our data just to get
over the very very intro of this stuff
so if we just wanted a single column of
our data set we can take our data set
use square brackets so square brackets
is in general how Python will some
subset objects and if we wanted for
example the country column we can just
put in square brackets in the string
country and it'll give us just the
country column right so what we could do
is we can take this and save this to a
variable right so we can say country you
know frame is just that command that we
just saw before all right so if we
wanted just to look at the first couple
of rows instead of all of that we can
also say dot head on that one important
thing is if we look at the type of this
if you have a single column in a data
frame what comes back is a series so you
can think of a data frame as a bunch of
columns each column is a series alright
so that's just how those two words end
up working together and you can think of
a series as almost like a numpy like a
wonderful one-dimensional numpy array
right so what happens if we want more
columns in our dataset sorry let's see
this is subset
so sometimes what you want to do is like
hey I have this giant data set but I
don't care about like all of these other
columns I only care about subset over
these columns so what you can do in
Python is if you're trying to specify by
name multiple things you can put in a
Python list so we have this outer set of
square brackets which is really telling
python hey I want to subset something
and then a list in Python is another set
of square brackets so that's why you'll
see double square brackets if you're
trying to pull out multiple columns at
the same time and so here if we wanted
country continent and year oops that's
because I spelled it wrong
so if we wanted multiple columns and
we're just trying to specify it by the
actual column names that we want we can
put that in a Python list and then put
that list object into how we subset data
frames one other thing to keep in mind
if we do pandas dot double underscore
version double underscore that's how you
get the current version of pandas that
you're working with this becomes really
important when you start googling and
trying to get help from Stack Overflow
that sometimes api's will break and
hopefully the Stack Overflow answer will
give you the version of pandas that
they're using or hopefully there's
another solution that is using something
more modern so that's how we subset
columns so what about rows
there's three different ways in the
actual Python API on how you can subset
rows two of them are recommended one of
them is deprecated or being deprecated
you'll get a big warning and not advised
so I'll cover all three of them and then
you know just tell you you only need two
you really only should work with one of
them so how do we get specific roads
that are idea set you can see here that
there is this index thing that we talked
about right so this index place of
important rules are how we subset rows
because this is going to be how we call
a specific row in our data set
so if for example we wanted to call this
you know to which is a third row in our
dataset but we're trying to reference it
by the actual like string to that you
see on the screen there is a way we can
subset data using LOC for essentially
location and if we give it a value for
example to it will look in that index
and see like hey what matches this thing
call - right it's not really looking at
like the index that the second index row
it's looking for the thing that matches
the symbol - right and this has some
consequences we won't really cover it in
this course or in this tutorial but if
you like concatenate data like start row
binding things together you can have
this situation where this row index is
duplicated and if you say LOC - you
actually get two rows back instead of
one because it's really looking at like
what is print being printed here which
is to write like that character - so if
we wanted to get multiple rows back just
like how we did with columns we put that
set in a Python list so if we wanted to
and 0 for example we'll get a data frame
back with 2 and 0 in the order that we
want right and again this is LOC and
it's really just doing almost like
character matching like I'm looking for
the thing called - so the other way that
we can subset data frames is using
something called I look so I'll oak and
the I stands for index so this is where
we're we're actually starting counting
from 0 and then saying like that is the
road that we're trying to get so if I
say I'll oak - this is really going me
to show you what this dataset looks like
i lo - is really going saying I'm
getting 0 1 2 that is the index position
that we want and that is the road that's
getting pulled back out all right so
there's like subtle difference between
the two in this example because the
index is really the same thing as the
row number it's a little hard to figure
out but you can imagine if you start
working with data sets and just
combining them sometimes you want that
thing labeled too and sometimes you want
like the actual position in the third or
index two in your data set the last way
if you look in the documentation there
is this way to access rows and rows
called I X or X and here if you try to
do anything in X or IX it will give you
a where is this a big giant deprecation
warning and it also says like please use
LOC or I loc instead I don't remember
the exact order but I think it sort of
works in it works as if you're using LOC
first and if they can't do that then
it'll drop down into I I look right and
so you can see it's kind of ambiguous
and so that's sort of why they're saying
like hey don't do this at all and you
might run into old code bases that
actually use IX and you know when you
see it try to fix it or talk to the guy
like did you mean like the label of the
row or the actual index position of the
row right and just sort of enforcing
your code to be a little bit more
readable by saying like hey we're this
thing that's ambiguous let's just get
rid of it so how do we get multiple rows
and columns that let's say we want to
subset our columns and also start
filtering by rows so they're really so
you end up using LOC to subset both rows
and columns and under the hood if you
really want to be like really verbose on
how you type this stuff
LOC if you've worked in are that the
notation would be really similar you can
have a comma and there's a portion to
the left of the comma and a portion to
the right up the comma how you specify
your rows is going to be to the left of
the comma and then how you want to
specify or subset your columns is to the
right of the comma so in our if sorry in
Python if we whoops if we for example
just wanted to get all of the columns
and keep all of the rows we can put this
slicing notation this call
that just says like hey give me
everything here and this just says hey
give me all of the rows and then on the
right hand side if we want in multiple
columns remember multiple columns we can
put in a Python list we can get all of
the rows in our data set and then just
filter by columns that way right
but this notation you know it really is
pretty silly in this case because we
could have just used the double square
bracket notation to begin with but this
has advantages because we can now also
do you know boolean subsetting of our
rows at the same time right so what does
that look like let's say we wanted our
data frame our we're basing it off of
the index label and in here let's say we
wanted you know year in 1967 right so
how do we specify we want all the rows
where the year is 1967 so we can really
say hey DF we're taking the Year column
and we want to make sure it is 1967 6
1967 and then if we wanted the year and
population we can do a filter for all of
the rows where our a year column is 1967
and then just subset specific columns
all right any questions so far that is
one more example we'll do one more
example if you're trying to do this
trying to do this boolean sub setting
and you want to do for example multiple
multiple conditions or multiple boolean
cases the trick is you have to wrap each
individual statement in a set of round
brackets so let's say we wanted year
that's 1967 and then also DF Pop greater
than I don't know
what is this 1/2 a million that seems
kind of low maybe this will work
other cool thing about Python numbers
like 10 or a thousand let's use a
thousand a thousand you can actually use
as a visual marker this underscore for
integers and it represents the same
thing right so if you need like the
equivalent of a comma to help separate
out your numbers Python sees one
underscore zero zero zero the same thing
as a thousand so again hopefully make
your code a little easier to read so I
have this these two boolean cases and if
we wanted both of those to be true we
can use the ampersand and if you want at
the or you use this vertical pipe for or
and the reason why the notation ends up
looking like this where you have to use
round brackets and an ampersand instead
of the regular Python a and D it's
really doing bitwise comparison and so
that's why I did code looks like that
alright cool so now to the actual
portions because we are now done with
the the the intro so if you downloaded
the data sets or that that folder there
is a folder called notebooks there is a
folder called notebook so let's go into
the notebooks folder and then create a
new Jupiter notebook in there so their
first notebook I can rename this and
I'll call this intro and then the second
one I will call this tidy right so the
key here is I am now in a different
folder from where all the data sets are
stored so that really just has some
implications of how we like load or find
our data sets but before we go there
and I'll put this link on the github
repo so you guys can find it but so
let's just talk about tidy data and what
what does it mean when your data set is
quote-unquote clean right and so there
is this really nice paper by Hadley
Wickham he comes from the our world but
you know stuff like this is totally
relevant it's language agnostic and so
what does it mean to have like clean
data sets right and that that's sort of
the reason what this paper talks about
it's like hey we have these two days
that's defined by table 1 and table 2
and you know which one is better like if
we talk about rows and columns it's
really ambiguous and that's what this
paper talks about like we actually need
like better words for these things all
right and then he also says like ok this
these two things contain the same bit of
information but then here's another
version of this data set in table 3 and
this is like the actual like tidy or
clean version of this data set and why
so you can imagine let's say you want to
fit a model a statistical model that is
like you know some result based off of
treatment right you can now actually
like fit a model that's like result is
your Y and treatment is your X right
like you have a comment for that versus
you know a data set like this you can't
you don't really have like what is the
column that is like my response variable
and then what is the column for my
inputs right so that's that's sort of
one visual cue to like well hey what
does it mean when data is clean the
other thing is like once you get your
data really into like a tidy format
lower so if you're just processing data
this is a pretty good target for like
what your final data set should look
like if you get your data set and format
like this it's pretty easy to convert it
to whatever you need right so like this
version of our data set it might be good
for statistical models but like if
you're trying to like show a table of
results like one of these two forms is
probably way better right like for a
given person you can really easily check
like treatment a and treatment B but
it's a little harder down here like hey
I'm looking for the Jane Doe it's a
result and you have to scroll down to
find like chained OB right so just
different versions of datasets and
they're all none one no one version is
better than the other they all serve
different purposes but the key is like
once you get your data in the clean or
tidy format it's pretty easy to convert
it to one another and that's what we'll
talk about
the formal definition of Tidy data he
talked hadley Wickham talks about in his
paper each variable forms a column each
observation forms a row each type of
observational unit forms a table will
probably really only talk about the
first two so what does it mean for each
variable forms a column each observation
forms a row let's look at this version
up here you can see that we have a
column called name a column called
treatment column called result right so
those are three separate variables that
means those are three separate potential
inputs into a model that we want to
define and in each observation forms a
row right so for a given person we have
like his or her treatment value and
their result a little bit more down on
this paper data is messy it's messy in
many many different ways but there's if
you also go through the process of like
cleaning or tidying your data sets
you'll probably end up going through the
first three problems right and so that's
what we'll go through in this tutorial
is just walk through these first three
things as defined in this paper and if
you do end up reading this paper will
actually like work with the exact same
data sets except for one of them you
really don't need to read the entire
thing by the time you get to chapter 4
or end of yeah by let me get the section
4 that's probably like all you need to
know the rest is really specific to our
but if you just want to understanding of
like hey what does it mean for data to
be like quote-unquote good the first
three sections is really all you need to
read all right so we have this other
notebook let us you know start
processing tidying our data this is a
new notebook so we do have to import our
libraries again one other way you can
import libraries is using this as
command so we can we can say import
pandas as PD and you can see what this
allows us to do is we can now instead of
writing PA and das dot something we can
now say P dot
so this is just a way this is called a
alias and it's just to help you simplify
your typing so you don't have to type so
much so the first data set will come
from the Pew Research Center and will
now use PD dot reason CSV instead of
pandas not read CSV to load our first
data set so in this example if we look
at my folder structure I have my stuff
in these in the notebooks folder but the
data set is really from this notebook
it's one folder up and down into a data
folder and then that's where my data
sets are right so instead of just typing
Gapminder like we did before we now have
to say two dots that says hey go one
folder up and then go down into the data
folder and then look up the PUE csv data
set so if we look at the head of this
data set this is the first this is
exactly the same data set shown in that
paper but you can see here is an example
of a data set that's not tidy but it's
really great in terms of you know
something that you show in a report so
for a given religion and again give an
income bracket I think this is like the
count count of people and so if we go
back up into this paper what is the
problem what are the three problems that
we will cover column headers are values
and not variable names what does that
mean well if you look at our columns you
can see that we have a bunch of columns
that are actually income brackets and
that really should be in one column
that's called like income and then on
the right-hand side we should probably
have like a count column that's just for
a given religion and income bracket
there's a count right alright so how do
we fix this type of problem there is
this notion of like long data and wide
data if you read the paper that's also
kind of ambiguous but I still need to
use it because that's how database
people also talk about things so you can
think of long data as like a lot more
rows since it's long versus Y data which
is just a bunch of columns right so in
this case this is an example
of wide data because we have a bunch of
columns that we really want into long
format right so hopefully if I show you
the code and run it make a little bit
more sense so if we are going from like
Y data to long data and this is the
reason why the function is named this
way you can think about like if you have
a sword and you're trying to melt the
sword
it goes from long wipe along so the
function that we're using is called melt
so pandas has a function called melt
because we're going from wide to long
and melt if we look at the function
signature so if you hit shift tab the
first object takes is a data frame and
so the data frame we want to melt is
called pew or PW and then there's a
bunch of other parameters in there so
one of those parameters is called ID
VARs and ID VARs essentially what you
are trying to do is you're trying to
take a bunch of columns and turn them
into one column right so you're going
from white to long and ID var is this
essentially saying hey what are what are
the column or columns that you don't
want to touch right and in in this
example we don't we want to leave the
religion column alone we actually want
to melt down all of the other columns so
we can say something like ID VARs as
religion meaning that is the column that
we don't want changed so let me save
that into a variable called pew long and
if we look at it we now - all of those
columns that wasn't specified by ID VAR
so religion and we converted them or
made them long into a column by default
it's called variable end value right so
if I don't use head hopefully this will
show you can see for a given religion we
have a income bracket and then like
account right and that that is the tidy
version of that data set right we have
each column is a variable so religion in
this case value variable and value each
row is now an observation
Segan oh the index our D&C is unique
I believe the indices are unique I have
to never actually ran into a situation
where like I was playing with indices
when I'm doing this so I don't know the
actual answer to your question but hold
on let me see maybe there is all right
so there isn't like a reset index yeah I
don't know I might I might play around
with it like afterwards all right so if
we look at this anything that you didn't
specify an ID VARs get thrown into this
other parameter called value bars right
so the function takes really two things
ID bars and value bars and whatever you
specify in value bars if you lead ID
bars alone that will be in there and
vice versa all right so you don't have
whatever is easier or shorter to type
that's the one that you use you can also
use both of them if you're also trying
to subset columns at the same time but
the other two parameters in here var
name and value name that's how we change
the default value variable and value
columns right so if we take the same
exact piece of code and we say var name
is now income we can also say value name
is not count now if we look at our data
set we actually get like some sensible
variable names for us right so yeah so
that so if you ever end up in this
situation when you have a bunch of
columns in there like hey those are
clearly like variables I want to put
into a model that's all you have to do
is turn this melt your data set specify
the columns we want fixed or the columns
you want melted and then you have your
tidy data set right so now you can do
something that's sort of like for a
given religion
like predict the count or something it's
like probably a terrible model that you
would want to fit but that's something
that you could do alright so what
happens if we want to work with more
more columns so there's another data set
in in the data sets so there is a data
set called billboard dot CSV and this we
really have the same problem we just
have a lot more columns right so for
let's look at any individual row we have
a year artist track time date enters so
these are all songs in in 2000 and then
we have its billboard like rating from
like week one I think it goes all laid
out - like week 72 and so this is a same
problem we have before right so we what
we really want is like a column called
like week number that's like week one
all the way to 72 and then it's actual
rating right so then you can do
something like you know for a given week
predict like the actual value or
something so this is the same problem
that we have before we have a bunch of
columns that are values instead of
variables right so if you go back to the
paper we're still in this column headers
or values not variable names problem
this is just a bigger version of that
problem so how do we melt this so we are
using the same melt function
right lips melt I will just be very
generous with my line break so it
doesn't flow off the screen so the code
is that exactly the same as before right
so if we want to melt the data set the
first thing you say is like hey what is
the dish that you want to melt so the
first parameter is going to be the data
set and then before when we specified
ID'd ours we only put in religion but in
this case we really want to hold we
really want to hold year artists track
time date entered like the same the
other two columns we don't want to
change and everything else we do and so
here we could just put in here artists
track time date entered all right so
these are the columns that we don't want
and then all of the others which is week
1 to 72 those are the columns that are
slated to be melted down so we don't
need to put in the value VARs parameter
in this case and then just to round off
the example let's just have when it does
this lets create like sensible names for
these things so we're gonna call the
columns those column names are now gonna
be in one column called week and then
value name we'll call that rating right
so now if you look at our data set we
get your artists track time date entered
for a given week what is that song's
rating right
why might you want to do something like
this again you can do this for modeling
purposes this is actually the definition
of liked ID data if you work with
databases databases prefer data and long
format so before you dump something into
a database you probably will end up
doing something like this
I had this example where we had like
this 1,000 by 1,000 row data set and we
try to dump it into Postgres and it
really didn't like the fact that we were
trying to put in a data set or a tabled
I had a thousand rows a thousand columns
and so what I had to do was actually
turn this into like this many many
thousand row object with like two
columns and then and then it was fine
right so different things need different
forms but you're also thinking about
databases this is also to format
databases prefer to do things in all
right so remember shape so billboard
shape this billboard dataset really had
originally had 317 rows and 81 columns
when I call this note see yeah yeah so
I'll just talk what I said so if you
look at the two of the shape of the two
data sets you'll notice that one has way
more rows than the other right sometimes
that's just what happens when you're
trying to tidy data you just end up with
like oh I only had like a hundred rows
before now I have a million well it's
really the same number cells but one is
definitely more favorable in terms of a
format for data storage and just
modeling in general all right all right
so let's go so that's usually the PD
that melt that's what you do when you
have that that first problem like I have
a bunch of column than I just want to
melt it down what happens if you have
multiple variables stored in one column
the paper will be using a different data
set from the paper so I just want to
show you what the paper has this comes
from a I think these are accounts TB
counts and you can look at one we
actually have the same problem as before
right like these column names are
actually values and they actually store
two bits of information right so the way
we read this m0 14 this dancer of male 0
to 14 and then we have the same thing
and it goes all the way up to like male
65 and above and then we have the same
thing for female 0 to 14 mixer etc right
so we know the first problem is like we
need to do something with melt because
what we would really want is a column
that's like male and an age group right
but we but the column name itself is
storing two bits of information so
that's a problem so how do we work with
that
so in our data set we have a dude sorry
I will load this before
alright so here we have a data set
called country time series and so this
is a data set for when I when I was just
about to join grad school I met with
another graduate student in the same
program I was going into her name was
Caitlin River she currently works at
Bloomberg School of Public Health I
believe at Hopkins and she curated this
data set from the 2014 Ebola outbreak so
at the time
Ebola was like first big outbreak in
West Africa countries were doing like
giving reports and she was kind of
reading those reading those reports and
just keep putting down these cases and
death counts that the countries were
reporting into a data set there's a
repository for all of this and I'll link
that as well but you can see this data
set has the same exact problem as before
we have cases Guinea and in a number of
cases and we scroll to the right we also
have something called death skinny and
then number that's right so what we
would really want is like a column
called date a column called day a column
that somehow distinguishes whether this
is a case count or a death count we also
want a column that is like the country
that this is account for and then
another column that is the actual count
right so that's the end goal when we
that we want so let us take a five
minute break so we can like go to the
bathroom get water etc etc so it is now
2:16 let's come back at 221 yes
ah yes you have to write like your code
for it but yeah he could you could
totally slice columns and without but
you have to write like other Python code
to do that yeah
so let's come back at 2:20 and then
we'll just pick up from there all right
220
it's actually muy fast I guess all right
but we have a lot to cover so let us
keep going so we have the data set and
what we want is you know we wanted those
specific homes date day country whether
or not it's a case count or a deaf count
and then the actual value this goes to
four o'clock right all right all right
so we know the first thing that we want
to do right we want if we if we melted
those columns down that gets us part of
the way there all right so let's say
let's do that first
ebola long is going to be PT melt so
that's exactly the same things before
and then ID bars the columns that we
want to hold the same in this case is
date whoops date and day all right cool
so that gets us part of the way there we
have dated a variable and value those
are the default names and then the only
problem here is this variable column now
contains two bits of information right
so that is the we did the first part and
now let's work on the second part so if
we look at this if I were to ask you
like hey so there's like case counts
test counts and in the country how would
you split this if I like without
programming in general you might just
say like hey there's like it really
convenient underscore there if we just
broke the column down by the underscore
the part to the left will be whether or
not this is a case count death count and
apart to the right that'll be our
country so we will do exactly that so
just to step out of the data
pandas world a little bit and back in
just back into pure regular Python if we
have this regular if you have the string
cases underscore Guinea Python has a lot
of string manipulation functions
that one of them is called split and by
default split will split on a space but
we can say like hey take the string and
break it up by some other delimiter
right this could be an underscore this
could be a word it's gonna be like
whatever you want and what comes back is
a Python list and then each element of
the list that's what the components
after its split was right so we need
something like this in our to work on
our column we want to be able to break
our variable in this case column by
cases and getting on the underscore so
the way we do that we can assign a value
so the column that we're looking for is
the variable column right so I didn't
really give these any special names so
the variable column and so the key part
is there is this thing called an
accessor called STR and this allows you
to take a column and like do string
things with it so STR stands for string
so now we can treat this column as a
string and now we have like we've open
up a bunch of methods from Python that
like work on strings one of them like I
just show you showed you what's called
split and what we want to do is split on
that underscore so now if we look at
variable split so we took this column
right so this column was just coming
over here we accessed this column as if
it was a string so STR and then we ran
the split method and what we get back is
this vector or this column of our string
split into two components so let's look
at this a little bit
so what we get back is a series so again
a series if you see series think of this
as a column of data if we for example
this is a series we don't need to lis
use lokor Iloka doesn't it's just one
vector so we can just say like if we
want the first element we can just say
Brad :
bracket zero and just to get the first
element out right so this gets the first
element out of a series every type fist
notice that this is a regular Python
list so if we from this list if we
wanted because we know this is a Python
list forget about working in the data
frame world just think how do I get
things out of that list we use square
brackets so if I wanted the first
element without using type for now we
can get cases by just pulling out the
first element and that is that type is
just a regular Python string right so
this is why like if you ever get
confused just run type off of everything
right it'll help you contextualize like
what your problem is
alright so before I was just like what
the heck is this thing I've never seen
this before it's a series so forget
about what's in there and just treat it
as a series and then you can slowly
break down your problem that way all
right so how do we get this all back
into our working with our data so the
first column or the first entity in this
list is what we want in terms of like
status will call cases or death and then
the second one is going to be country so
how do we like in one go just get all of
the first elements so if we take
variable split so that's that and if we
say I think if we just use 0 yeah so you
can say like hey treat this thing as a
string and then just get the first thing
out of it you can use dot STR you can
use that accessor again and then put a
bracket 0 I like to be a little bit more
explicit
and say get use get just so I can say
like hey treat this thing as a string
get things out and then get the first
element out so like people have told me
like how is this any different from your
using square bracket zero there isn't
really I just like to use the word get
it just helps for me every read a little
nicer so that's how we get that first
column right so that's what we want and
then if we wanted to get the second
element we can just say get one and then
we get the country's so we can use those
two components to break up that column
so the data set we've been working with
this entire time was called Ebola long
and if you wanted to create a new column
just pretend that column always existed
so we can subset this column just like
before and we can say status is now
equal to that thing right so remember
when we ran get it gave us a vector back
of whether this was a case count or a
death count and then we can copy and
paste that column again that code line
of code again and we can say we want
another column called country and that
is the second element in that data set
and now if we look at our data set we
got we took with the code I just
selected broke up that original variable
column and we reassigned it to two new
columns and so if you ever end up in a
situation where like you have columns
both stored like for a given column it's
storing two bits of information what you
end up having to do is a melt and then
some kind of string manipulation to
break this thing up there's another so
that's like the very manual way of doing
all of this there's a there's another
way you can do this like essentially in
one go which I'll show you so if we go
back and we look at the original command
called split
split actually has a parameter called
expand and if we set it to true instead
of giving back a list of a vector of
lists it would just give us an actual
data frame back right and you can see
here it gave us a data frame it didn't
know what to call these columns it just
gave us 0 1 oh this is something that we
can work with so if you really wanted to
take that thing that I just showed you
and do it in one go you can do something
like Ebola long and also remember when I
said if you wanted to assign stuff to a
column make a new column just pretend
that thing always existed so if you
again remember selecting multiple
columns in a data frame used two sets of
square brackets so if we just pretended
that status expanded or country expanded
if we just pretend those columns always
existed we can assign columns that way
all in one go one other thing that
you'll see really often is if you have
really long bits of code the Python
community tends to wrap that whole thing
in a set of round brackets so I put one
here in Ebola long at the very end and
then in between like where you have
these dot notations you can break up and
create a new line you'll see that very
often in the Python documentation on
like if code just gets starts to run off
the screen all right cool all right so
we worked with the first two sets of
data so column headers are values not
names multiple variables stored in one
column what happens when variables are
stored in both rows and columns what
does that look like so we have a data
set for that
all right let's look at this data set
called weather so this this data set the
first thing you'll notice that okay you
have d1 d2 d3 both are a we're probably
going to melt something that's something
that we've seen already but how do we
know that a data set has essentially
data like everywhere one of the symptoms
of something like this if we look at
these two columns right here if you end
up in a situation where pretty much the
vast majority of this row is duplicated
except for like one value you probably
have this problem or like data is being
stored in what was the symptom called
variables are stored in both rows and
columns so you so if you have a row of
data where a lot of information is
repeated except for a few numbers that's
how you know that variables are actually
being stored in a row that's one of the
symptoms and so let's look at this data
set we have I think a temperature I want
to say this is in Fahrenheit but I also
don't know what country this is in so
this doesn't help but so we would really
want like some ID the year the month the
day so the day information is stored in
columns and then for this element we
want like the column that's like
temperature max and in another column
that's like temperature min right that's
what we want at the end but we have this
problem we're like hey this team in and
T max stuff is actually in this column
called element right so in reality what
we're trying to do is like hey I just
spent all this time melting data how do
you do the opposite of melting right so
what we really want is take this element
to column and actually pivot those
values back up into columns themselves
individual column so we want a column
called T Max and a column called T min
what we don't want is a column called
element where there are values for T min
and P max all right so how do we fix
this problem
well the first thing we've seen like
over and over again we have these days
stored in columns so let's fix that part
first
so we'll be using this melt function
again so this is the third time that
we're seeing this so we pass in our
weather data and you know the columns
that we want to hold consistent or not
touch is the ID the year the month and
elements the let's actually give these
things sensible names so when we pivot
this down those d1 d2 d3 both just call
this day and then this value name we
will call temp for temperature and I
clearly spelled something wrong it was
great oh okay that's not too bad cool
live coding is great all right so just
like before that that got us part of the
way there right so you can see here this
symptom is like even more pronounced all
right so we fixed the day being columns
problem but now we have like ID
year-month-day temp and like the only
thing that's different is like whether
or not this is a min temperature or max
temperature right so like pretty much
everything suffer like one value is
duplicated in this data set and that's
that's like the sign that leahey
something something's like a little
weird another way you can think about
like hey what is the problem now I was
like hey if you wanted to fit a model
based off like year month and day and
you wanted temperature as your response
how would you like you want like the one
of the predictors to be like the min or
max temperature right like you don't
it's actually like a terrible example
but you don't have anyway the specified
min temperature max temperature you just
have this column called element right
and that's not really being helpful so
if you think about it in like in the end
a lot of people want to end the finian
model so if you think about like how
would you fit a model that's another way
to like diagnose like what your
current problem is alright so what is
the next part the next part uses this
function called pivot I use pivot table
but the example will show you pivot
table but I want to just show you that
light there's two things going on so you
could in this example you could also use
the method or function pivot the
difference between pivot and pivot table
is you can for example let's say let's
just look at the first two rows let's
say I am like a researcher and I'm like
out in the Arctic and I'm just taking
temperature readings in this example I
have one temperature for men and one
temperature for max but let's say I like
have another collaborator that's also
taking temperature readings that's going
to have the same year month and day and
and he's gonna have another set of
temperature min and Max values alright
so now you can think like forgiven the
Year month and day I have duplicate
values for for a specific temperature if
you use pivot the function it doesn't
know how to handle duplicate values
right so for for 2010 January 1st the
maximum temperature
well it's missing but let's say that
there are two values for that when I do
a pivot like just like in Excel when you
do a pivot table it doesn't know what to
do with like I can't handle multiple
values alright so in Excel when you do a
pivot table I think like by default it
takes like the mean or something and so
that's what pivot table will give you is
you get to specify here an aggregation
function so you can say like hey I want
the sum I want the mean I want the min I
want the Max etcetera etc so those are
the subtle differences between pivot and
pivot table in this case I'll just show
you pivot table but just note that like
if you're using pivot you're making an
assumption that like there are no
duplicates after our duplicates your
codes gonna crash it's gonna throw an
error so how do we do how do we work
with this function
oh so the newer versions the newer
version of pandas actually had like a
small API change so before I've been
using PD melt this entire time you could
have very easily have used weather dot
melt and called the data frame directly
and it would have done the same thing
that was one minor change so you can
also you can use can use PD melt or
write they both call the same exact code
and the reason why I bring that up is
because the PivotTable function you
still only work on weather dot pivot
weather long melt PivotTable used to
only exist as a data frame method and so
like people are like why do I have to
use PD melt in one case and then data
frame dot PivotTable in the other case
so they sort of like unified the
interface that way so you can use data
frame melt or PD melt in both cases
alright so how does this pivot table
function work we pass in actually it's
just way easier for me to the explain it
so just like before we had like index
bars or ID VARs here we specify hey what
are the columns that we don't want to
move so we don't want to move so we have
to use a Python list cuz we're using
multiple columns you don't want to move
ID we don't want to move here we want we
want to keep month the same and then day
the same
what in the columns parameter what is
the column that we actually want to do
this pivot so here we are saying pivot
this element column so what it's going
to do is it's going to look at this
element column for each unique value in
this column it's going to create a
totally separate column so that's the
element column and when we do this pivot
we now have to say like hey we just
created in this case two new columns
what are the values that we put in when
we do this manipulation and then when
you pass in this values parameter and we
just say hey use this temp column here
for temperature and use that to populate
after we do this manipulation so now if
we look at this we get what we need it
just prints out like a little wonky so
we have now a column call ID column
called year comic-con month and day and
then we also have a temperature max and
temperature min depending on what
version of pandas are using I think
there's also a parameter in here called
drop na so this will drop missing values
so that's why you don't have a bunch of
na s
for for example January it's only
showing D 30 depending on what value of
pandas you might just have all of them
as missing all right so you have this
data set and this is almost exactly what
we want but it's just printing out
differently one of the sort of tricks
that I do is like this is a hierarchical
index it's like there's a hierarchy in
the columns and rows going on here
part of so I also in my day to day I
jump for like any given hour or day of
the week I'm either using our Python so
I try to just bring everything down to
like the lowest common denominator and
so I just want to work with like a
regular flat data frame right so the way
we do that is there is this method
called reset index and if you run reset
index and you have this weird hierarchy
thing going on and you know it's a bit
hard you think just be just by the way
it's printed red late if you ever have
that and you're just like okay if I
pretend to treat this as a data frame
it'll work for most time but like
there's some weird edge case there are
some weird edge cases going on
but if you just want like a regular flat
data frame just run reset index and I'll
just flatten everything down for you and
sometimes you have to run reset index
like twice so I wouldn't worry too much
about that alright and now we have like
a nice tidy data frame for our weather
data set all right
last part what do we do when multiple
tables multiple types of observational
units are stored in the same table so an
example of that was our billboard
dataset if you think about like how
databases work or if you like work with
databases or where or if you are a
database administrator and if we looked
at the tidy version of our data set of
our billboard data set you can see like
your artists track time date entered
like there are 72 weeks like for any
given song there's like 72 rows of
information right this stuff that I have
highlighted is repeated 72 times and so
if you think of it in terms of like just
data storage like this is now leaving
the realm of like working with data for
like modeling purposes because this is
the format that you need from modeling
but if you're thinking about just
storing data you have this stuff here
repeated 72 times right like that's that
could get really bad very quickly and so
let's look at for example you know let's
look at this data set such that the
track is the song loser loser oh right
like this song by three doors down is
repeated in our data set a bunch of time
76 times in fact right so that's not
good so how do we kind of fix this stuff
up so like our data sets are a little
bit more like storage and data base
person friendly
I showed you guys how to filter your
data set so it's really just a
combination of like filtering your data
set with like drop drop duplicates right
so let us take our so we want to create
like a song's data set which just holds
information about our songs so how do we
do that
well that's our billboard melt and
what's information stored in songs it's
just your artists track time I'll leave
the date entered like separate but it's
fine right so we have our Billboard
songs right so this is the stuff that
was like repeated like 76 times all
right so if we look at our shape we have
like two 24 thousand rows in this but if
we run this command called drop
duplicates it will return back another
data frame such that all of the
duplicate rows are no longer there
so let's reassign this back to our data
set and now if we look at shape it's
really like 317 right so you can clearly
see like we went from 20,000 to 317 and
this just for data storage like this
could save you a bunch of time all right
so if you think about I didn't talk
about merging data sets together or
anything but if you think about like hey
I have a song's data set that's great
and I'm gonna eventually create like a
ratings data set that's great how do I
combine those two data sets together
like how do I join those two tables if
you know anything about joining tables
you need like an actual key so let's
generate a key so how do we generate a
key well one way is really to say we're
going to make a new column called ID so
every song will have an ID in our data
set and we can use this Python function
called range and we can say hey
generated an ID and it's based off of
how many rows are in our song
so what does this look like it creates a
column called ID so that's what's going
on here
range is a function in Python that just
you give it a number it'll generate a
value it's really a generator but think
of it as a list from zero to that number
right so it created zero to 316 for our
317 songs right so that just created our
ID for us and if we want now if we if
you really want you can say songs to CSV
and you can save this so billboard songs
dot CSV what you want to do when you
save this stuff there is a parameter
called index set at the faults otherwise
you get this nameless column in your
data set which you probably don't need
or we're not using an index in this case
so we don't need it and that's how you
save out your song's data set all right
you're using this to underscore CSV save
out your song's data set so now we kind
of need to backtrack a little bit and
get another totally separate data set
that is like for a given a song ID what
is their weak and rank for that week so
we need to go back a little bit and we
need to join these two tables together
so we eventually want to create a data
set called billboard ratings and we're
going to take our original full data set
before we filtered our songs out and
what we're going to do is merge these
two tables together the songs table and
the original one why why do we want to
do this it's because we actually need
this ID column that we've just created
right otherwise we just have like this
ID column where this song's data said
that we can't really do anything with so
we're going to do a merge and the data
set okay I'm pretty sure I can just
do this on the fly so the data said that
we want to merge is this songs data set
in merge so you can see we have a
literally the left data set isn't if you
read your code from left to right what
is the data frame that shows up on first
so left will be billboard melt right wil
be billboard songs that whoo that's what
we just provided how by default is inner
meaning that only the tables that found
matches will be returned back you can do
left left right inner outer etc etc if
you want there is a column called on so
fall if both tables have the same exact
column names you can use on equals if
the column names or on the left data
frame two are not the same as the column
name on the right you can say left on
right on in this example our columns
names are the same so we can say on and
we can say we are merging on your
emerging on here artist track and time
now if we look at Billboard ratings all
we did was like a really fancy way of
like getting this one column this ID
column but that's good because now we
have like ho for ID 0 which is this
Tupac song if we go back you can see
that ID 0 is just this song by Tupac
so now that we have our ratings or that
ID part there we do the same thing that
we did with songs which is filtered the
columns that we want drop duplicates and
then we can save that out so ratings is
billboard ratings and what are the
columns that we care about the columns
we cared about in this case is ID date
entered and then week
and then reading right so just like
before when I showed you or at the very
beginning
we're just all we're doing is filtering
our columns and that's all we did Segan
the IDS aren't all zero is it just so
happens to be zero so let me just say
like sample I think I think this works
yeah if I kind of just pick a random
sample of this you see like the IDS are
actually different and like these ID
numbers now if we want we can go back to
our songs dataset look up an ID and
we'll actually know what song it is and
then that's it if you want you could
drop duplicates I very much doubt that
there are duplicates in this example but
if we want we can then say to CSV save
this out to billboard ratings dot CSV
set index it goes equals to false and
then we'll have our two data sets if we
look at info ratings songs and then I
think it was just
sort of the order is messed up but if we
look at info one of the things down here
is like the actual memory usage of this
data frame and so if you look at our
original data frame we have like 1.3
plus megabytes if we look at the
separate ones they are actually much
smaller in terms of data set size right
so again the last point of Tidy data is
more for data storage if you're actually
gonna combine data or fit a model or
something what you're doing is like
combining and doing the merge together
and getting the full 1.3 megabyte data
set loaded in memory but in terms of
storage this is way easier to store
right like you've cleaned your data set
up break it up into separate pieces just
so if you have to zip this up and email
it to someone or if you're at a
conference and the Wi-Fi is really bad
this stuff just downloads faster and
then you know part of your data process
is assembly and combining the data sets
that you need for analysis all right so
that is we go back to this paper that is
all five points of this paper right
column headers are values not variable
names that's essentially just melt the
thing variables being stored in multiple
places as really some kind of melt and
then some string manipulation or some
kind of string processing that's usually
the general workflow of going on there
variables being stored in both rows and
columns well you treat that into really
two separate pieces
treat it as variables being stored in
column column so that's a melt and then
whatever you need you pivot back up so
the opposite of melt and then the last
two the technical term is called
normalization so you're normalizing your
data
break break information up into as many
like logical pieces make your database
person happy databases themselves will
be happier and then what you do is like
this combination of joins when you're
ready to light work with your data sets
this way someone doesn't have to load up
like this massive thing if they actually
care about like those two other
components versus you know the two that
you already have combined together and
the last one was like a single
observational unit stored in multiple
tables so that is essentially when we
our billboard dataset that we had
originally that is this last problem
right so when you're ready to do your
analysis you're kind of like not making
your data go here like adhere to the
last point because you're actually
combining your data sets together
because this data set now contains song
data and rating data but that's what you
need for analysis so that is it I am on
time so if you guys have any questions
there are microphones people running
around but hopefully that gives you the
big intro into pandas and this was sort
of just like show you how to work with
pandas load stuff uploaded data set
subset stuff and then we get to like I
really like talking about this paper
because my job is like processing and
cleaning data so this is a pretty good
paper just about what does it mean for
data to be clean and if you end up like
learning or having to learn another
language this way this paper or just
thinking about how to clean and tidy
your data that is a pretty good way to
like learn another language because
you're not you don't care about like
what is the function called you just
need to know I need to do this step how
do i do a melt in our right so that's
that makes stuff a lot easier
so the question is about like how do you
chain stuff and make it look like are in
general I think that's like what you're
trying to reach
so the I'm trying to find like the
example of code that was alright here it
is alright so there's like two different
like R in Python they're really like
fundamentally like very different
programs and the way that they're
handled like R is functional very
functional and pythons very
object-oriented and so how do you make
your code like look like it's chaining
together is first you wrap like your
commands around round brackets and what
ends up being the result of this stuff
is like what is the type of this well
that's just a regular data frame right
so you can treat all this code here as a
regular data frame and so if I wanted to
so in this example what I ended up
having to do was also like run the reset
index to reset this thing together
so if how would you actually chain this
while you literally say like rethought
reset index because the data frame
itself knows how to reset an index so
that is the closest to like chaining
there is in pandas so if you also want I
think like this is like I think it's
called selectable cheese it could be
yeah so if you wanted to you can also
use this method called select to like
filter rows and columns right so then
you'll end up doing something like this
dot select dot something dot something
so that's that's the pandas Python way
of chaining things together just in
general so teacher-man how to fish in
the Python pandas documentation you know
there is a bunch of stuff in here but
there is this other section called API
reference on the bottom and this is like
everything there is to know like all of
the functions available to you
in pandas so for example I showed you
guys the s dot STR accessor and so in
here if you were to look up STR dot was
a split there is that's how you find
like the definition for split right so
if you're curious you can also look up
like what can a data frame do so if you
end up on the page of like what is a
pandas dataframe you scroll down a
little bit you can see all the
attributes a data frame has so like T if
you just need to transpose so it's dot
capital T I showed you I X dot LOC
then you have all of the methods down
here right so you like melt reset index
etc etc all of that stuff is here and
this is all the stuff a data frame can
do and if you can find what a data frame
frame can do then you can just dot chain
them together and that's the equivalent
of training in order questions that sort
of follow up on that question curious if
you in your shop if you've seen or you
use a preference or best practice around
working in pandas if you know that you
want to index particular columns but you
also do a lot of training for
readability if there's a preference of
best practice around accessing brackets
versus the dot notation if you know
you're gonna be chaining extensively I
don't know if there's like an actual
best practice I use a square bracket
notation a lot very just that's just how
like my are scripts look like that I
wouldn't say there is like a best
practice really what what ends up really
happening at least this is like me
speaking for myself it's like you'll
write a bunch of code just to make stuff
work and then like you hopefully you go
back and like clean up your code later
if this is one giant like data
processing pipeline you might want to
just end up writing everything in a dot
notation just so it looks
a little clearer but in terms of like
how do you like run your script like
write it originally from the beginning I
just write it like if I'm assigning a
new column I'll just write you know
square bracket a new column equals this
other thing I don't I haven't really
written my stuff into using this
chaining notation very often other than
like you know if I'm running like a
group by that's that's usually where
I'll see you'll see a lot of chaining or
like data frame grouped by this select
these columns and then plot this thing
like so when I personally when I write
my code like the training stuff ends up
being like pretty like this is actually
trying to do one thing I'm not trying to
like run my entire data analysis
pipeline in training mainly because if
something goes wrong you have to unchain
the whole thing and so sometimes I just
write things like if it goes wrong at
least like I don't have to like undo
like 50 lines of code so yeah and then
you might end up in a situation where
like some some things like a data frame
just doesn't have a method for already
so like you just can't chain it so oh
yeah okay so that's that's time I
believe I'll be around today and also
around the conference the next two days
so if you want say hello
hopefully tomorrow there's I have a big
stack of books that I will be giving
away so we will hopefully you guys win
one find one by me
[Applause]